bring in Tennessee Republican senator
Marcia Blackburn now Senator great to
see you on this Tuesday afternoon it's
hard to believe what the president said
just there and if anybody missed it play
it out
why go to a border state and not visit
the Border because they're more
important thing going on they're going
to invest billions of dollars in a new
Enterprise
well there's a lot of important things
going on a lot of problems but certainly
the border is one of them senator
indeed the border is one of those in
making certain that we secure that
border and Sandra the border patrol has
been saying for 30 years they need a
barrier at the border they need
technology where you cannot get that
barrier and they need more officers and
agents it is important to protect this
nation it is important that we stem the
flow of illegal immigrants coming into
this country when you look at the
numbers that are crossing and are giving
themselves up when you look at the known
godaways the unknown gotaways when you
look at the number of terrorists that
are coming into this country when you
look at the drugs the drug trafficking
The Gangs the human trafficking sex
trafficking it is imperative that we get
this border secure and the president
owes it to the American people he owes
it to the border patrol he owes it to
the citizens of Arizona to go there and
see firsthand what is going on and he
refuses to do it yeah as far as the
reaction we've seen Brandon Judd put out
a statement immediately you just heard
it from Mike Tobin saying nothing's more
important than the Safety and Security
of the American people but President
Biden he says that is an afterthought
here's chip Roy the representative from
Texas's 21st district reacting to the
president
sure is something that's pretty
critically important to people of Texas
and frankly to the immigrants that are
getting abused and dying 53 in the
tractor trailer San Antonio getting
raped in stash houses in South Texas or
how about the 72 000 people who died
from fentanyl last year the moms that I
have to talk to every day who's lost a
loved one because Fenton was born into
our border because he refuses to secure
the southern border we all know the
truth he my orcas they're all teaming up
to endanger Americans uh and uh you know
poking his head in the sand isn't going
to actually be enough she's gonna have
to do something about it so he's going
to have to do something about it says
chip Roy do you believe that'll ever
happen I mean there is there are growing
calls for him to do so and it's not just
Republicans anymore you've seen a lot of
these Democrats down in some of these
border districts saying the president
needs to get down here and see firsthand
what is what is happening
that's right and seeing it firsthand is
important because right now it appears
that it is very intentional for this
Administration to ignore the border to
Leave It Wide Open to let people come in
and it is imperative to protect the
people of this country when you talk to
these parents that have lost their
children to drugs when you talk to Law
Enforcement Officers you realize every
town in this country is a Border Town
every state is a border state because of
all the drugs the trafficking The Gangs
the uptick in crime and it is all
related Sandra and people are saying do
something about this when I'm talking to
Tennessee sheriffs and they're telling
me what cities the cartels are operating
in and where the drugs are coming from
that they are apprehending on the
streets that is a signal to to this
Administration get your act together get
this border secured work with the border
patrol stop working against them and
against the safety of the American
people Senator I've only got 30 seconds
left here I just want to play this real
quick this is the Press secretaries for
the president claiming the president's
gone to the Border real quick
he's been there he's been to the Border
I will have to get look back in my
history books and check the times he's
been to the southern when he did drive
through the Border when he was on the
campaign Trail in 2008 I've only got a
few seconds left but why continue to
insist that this president has gone to
the can you explain that yeah I cannot
it is just beyond the pale I mean you
know a drive-by is not the same thing as
boots on the ground and the American
people know that the people are smart
Sandra they want to see this border
secured and this Administration needs to
do it all right Senator I really
appreciate your time today thank you
very much for joining us okay I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis